[Musik]
dass mir schlecht
herzlich willkommen ja unsere hemmungen
unsere scham ist es die uns menschen von
den schimpansen unterscheidet das meint
der schweizer liedermacher mani matter
in einem schönen stück wenige die scham
sie hemmt uns tatsächlich viele schöne
dinge zu tun aber sie schützt uns eben
auch der vor moralische fehler zu
begehen ist die schau nun also etwas
gutes oder etwas schlechtes und erlebt
sie gerade heute eine hochblüte wo die
rede ist von ihm charme von flug oder
auch von public schelling in den
sozialen medien
das alles will ich herausfinden und zwar
zusammen mit der philosophin und charme
expertin maria sybilla lotter herzlich
willkommen vielen dank für die einladung
jafran o2 was müsste dann in der
folgenden stunde passieren damit sie
sich so richtig schämen würden
ich muss gestehen ich habe schon
vorgebeugt heute morgen
ich wollte nämlich erst ein ganz helles
hemd anziehen und dann fiel mir ein dass
ich schon einmal in einer situation war
als mir dann im zug der kaffeebecher um
viel und ich dann mit einem riesigen
kaffeefleck so eben auch einer sendung
fuhr und dann will ich konnte mir ganz
schnell vorher noch einen schal kaufen
um diesen fleck zu verbergen erfolgreich
begleiten aber insofern habe ich
vorgebeugt und hoffe dass nichts mehr
passiert kleidung ist ja etwas wofür
sich manche jugendliche schirm gerade in
der pubertät zum beispiel oder diese
stoffe aus lehrern ist auch eine
situation von kontrollverlusts sind auch
viele situationen ins schema ja was
sagen denn die momente wo sie sich
schämen persönlich über über sie aus aus
personen
ja ich denke kontrollverlust ist schon
das richtige thema also hin so ein
mit dem kaffeebecher ich erinnere mich
noch wie das im zug passierte und ich
fand das im ersten moment unglaublich
komisch und dann wahnsinnig peinlich und
beunruhigend weil ich dachte jetzt jeder
schaut mich an mit diesem kaffeefleck
und dann fand ich sehr komisch nicht
es war das gros im sinne von sekunden
darüber lachen und über das ich jetzt
hier über lachen weil das bei dieser es
war ja eine eine irgendwie absurde
situation und nichts was ich mir jetzt
wirklich im strengen sinne zum vorwurf
machen würde wenn ich bin an meine
schusseligkeit und kann mit ihr leben
aber er aber in der situation wenn man
unmittelbar jemandem gehe vor hat
jemanden gegenüberzutreten dem man noch
nicht kennt das ist aber eine
halboffizielle situation derweil wäre
das natürlich sehr unangenehm gewesen
aber da drin ist schon dieser blick der
anderen auf einen selbst oder sie sagen
sie sind an ihre schusseligkeit gewöhnt
aber die anderen nicht entziehen
an diesem fleck und irgendwie schenken
und sich auch wenn man so etwas entdeckt
als aussenstehende personen an zusagen
sowie irgendjemand den hosenstall zum
beispiel offen hat genau genau also es
wenn man auf taktvolle personen trifft
werden die natürlich so tun als seien
sie nichts auch wenn es ein sehr großer
fleck ist schauen wenn man jemanden
schon kennt und weiß man kann sich
darauf verlassen dann ist das auch ein
beruhigendes gefühl aber sobald man mit
unbekannten zu tun hat oder umgeben ist
von fremden wie im zug ist das eine ganz
andere situation nicht und dann gerät
man ins schwanken wie nehmen die mich
jetzt war und auch wenn man eigentlich
an etwas gewöhnt ist und sich selbst
keinen vorwurf machen würde
zieht man sich in einer solchen
situation automatisch mit den augen der
anderen
jetzt sind sie ja philosophie
professorin an der ruhr universität in
bochum haben an der universität zürich
habilitiert und sich intensiv mit dem
thema befasst etwa hier in diesem buch
charme schuld und verantwortung ich habe
mich gefragt wenn man sich länger mit
dem thema charme beschäftigt
wie verändert dass das eigene scham
empfinden kann man die charme damit
derzeit auch besser überwinden oder
zigarren bis stückweit kontrollieren
ich glaube nicht dass man sie leichter
überwinden und kontrollieren kann
aber es ist insofern es verändert schon
etwas
als man dann beginnt seine eigenen
charme erlebnisse genauer zu beobachten
und das ist ungeheuer interessant nicht
denn wenn man sich mit der scham anderer
personen beschäftigt für dieses buch in
dem es ja darum geht etwas über die
konstitution von personen herauszufinden
habe ich auch etwas über andere charme
kulturen charme auslösende situation in
anderen kulturen gelesen und dann
vergleicht man das mit den eigenen
erfahrungen und fängt an zu beobachten
also dann schäme ich mich jetzt
eigentlich und wann nicht welche rolle
spielen da jetzt die anderen inwiefern
ist das etwas was mit meinen eigenen
vorstellungen wie ich sein sollte zu tun
hat oder schäme ich mich auch in
situationen in denen ich mich überhaupt
nicht schämen würde wenn ich alleine
wäre und das ist offensichtlich der fall
interessant das heißt es gibt situation
nur die scham verräterisch ist und
sozusagen meine meine werte meine
idealen ein ideales selbst in die
offenbar wird was ich sein möchte
nämlich nicht jemand mit einem
kaffeefleck auf t shirts und andere
situation wo sie sagen da kommt nichts
von meiner person zum ausdruck sondern
eher so etwas wie soziale erwartungen
oder konventionen ja also man kann sich
über dinge die für andere menschen
vielleicht gar kein problem wären aber
die etwas mit den eigenen idealen zu tun
haben ich also mit es können auch sehr
spezielle ehrgeiz vorstellungen seien
die man vielleicht nicht realisiert es
kann aber auch passieren und das war für
mich eine neue entdeckung weil ich immer
dachte ich bin unabhängiger als als ich
dann tatsächlich erfahren habe kann mich
auch einfach über situation zutiefst wo
ich mich plötzlich sozial ausgeschlossen
fühlen obwohl mir dann bewusst war ich
das bewusst wahrscheinlich auch gar
nicht so gedacht hätte dass ich wert
darauf gelegt
habe gerade von diesen personen
anerkannt zu werden und ich also ich
habe immer so ein bisschen so eine
eigene eigenbild dass der rebellin
kultiviert und dazu passt es nicht dass
man unbedingt von allen gemocht werden
will aber wenn man einmal genauer auf
seine gefühle achten
in bestimmten situationen und merkt was
da abläuft dann merkt man dass es noch
eine zweite ebene gibt nicht nur der
verstorbene ja ja genau genau die
eventuell ganz anders tickt als diesem
selbstbild entspricht und heißt das denn
das sich dem gefühl mehr trauen sollte
also wenn ich jetzt mich schäme vor
personen wo ich denken würde von der von
denen muss ich mich überhaupt nicht
schön ich brauche deren anerkennung
nicht die sie mir nicht wichtig genug
das gefühl ist trotzdem da heißt das ich
lerne etwas über mich selbst nämlich für
mich sind diese personell richtig
ja ich denke schon also da also das
achten auf diese auf dieser effekte dass
man sie ernst nimmt und nicht einfach
beiseite tut das zeigt einem schon etwas
über verschiedene ebenen der eigenen
person und auch die beziehungen zu
anderen haben sie gesagt sie haben nach
so interkulturelle vergleiche gemacht
aber geschaut wie inwiefern man sich
oder wofür man sich schämt in anderen
kulturen gibt es denn dinge für die sich
alle menschen schämen
also es gibt sicher überall eine körper
charme
also es gibt bestimmte formen der charme
ich glaube das ist auch in einer anderen
sendung hier thematisiert worden wie
menstruation star
das kommt wohl fast überall vor ist in
der sternstunde religion direkt vor
unsere serie
aber für was man sich schämt oder was
die scham erfordert ist extrem
unterschiedlich nicht also es gibt eine
ganz interessante passage in einem buch
von max scheler dem philosophen wo er
darüber sie darüber nachdenkt wie es
denn in afrika ist wo die menschen ja
weniger bekleidet sind und die
missionare immer versucht haben also die
dass man sie als harmlos wahrgenommen
haben zu ändern indem sie dann
europäischer kleidung einführten nicht
und schüler überlegt dass das doch
gerade die umgekehrte wirkung
haben muss nicht denn in kulturellen
umständen wo es sehr heiß ist wo die
menschen die ich gewohnt sind sich mit
so etwas wie eng europäischer kleidung
zu belasten
dann wird die werden die aufgaben der
scham anders verteilt das heißt
diejenigen die blicken die müssen ihren
blick abwenden oder ihren blick auf eine
neutrale weise halten nicht so dass sie
diejenigen die ihren körper präsentieren
nicht sehen ja sie auch nicht system
also die aufgaben werden in kulturen
sehr unterschiedlich verteilt was die
körper scharmann ging also nicht nur
endlich müssen sich die frauen verhüllen
ja in anderen ist es aufgabe der männer
wegzuschauen ich zuschauen interessant
also manchmal muss ich mich selbst
sozusagen verdecken die das wofür ich
mich schämen und machen dann müssen die
anderen weggucken ist es denn möglich
prinzipiell dass man sich für alles
mögliche schämt also jetzt für meine
kleidung für mein auto meine familie
aber auch für zb für ein erfolg für die
talente für für reichtum kann man sich
prinzipiell für alles mögliche schäden
ich glaub ich glaube prinzipiell schon
das hängt eben ganz davon ab wie die
wertvorstellungen sind die gerade in
einer gesellschaft kursieren welche man
selbst verinnerlicht hat welchen man
sich verpflichtet fühlt
es hat natürlich auch mit
selbstvertrauen zu tun mich also wenn
jemand wenig selbstvertrauen hat dann
wird er vielleicht einerseits versuchen
der norm der möglichst leistungsstark zu
sein gerecht zu werden
aber wenn er dann freunde hat die gerade
so was verachten und der auffassung sind
man sollte sich nicht um die
leistungsgesellschaft kümmern und da
sind doch streber und das ist doch ein
furchtbares leben dann wird er sich
bemühen auch dieser norm gerecht zu
werden und dann kann man sich natürlich
nur schämen
also wer weil es keine möglichkeit gibt
allen gerecht zu werden
und man sieht dann aber immer abwertende
blicke jetzt haben sie selbstvertrauen
gesagt ist das denn ein wichtiger
gegenbegriff zu charme
es gibt ja noch den stolz zum beispiel
was ich aber sagen das gegenteil von
charme also das gegenteil von charme ist
ja erst mal wörtlich die schamlosigkeit
aber die hat natürlich verschiedene
betreut so dass fehlender charme das ja
es kann also einerseits meinen wir damit
leute die den ist an scham fehlt es kann
aber auch bedeuten also dass jemand
absichtlich auch wenn es eben gar nicht
an charme fehlt absichtlich sagen wir
mal in opposition zur schamhaft ich kite
auftritt nicht das schamlose benehmen
das soll auch eine vorwärtsverteidigung
sein
gerade deswegen weil es immer leichter
ist psychologen sprechen dann von der
verschiebung von charming schuld wenn
ich also wenn wenn ich mich in den
blicken der anderen spiegele und wertlos
fühle dann ist das ein großer
kontrollverlust und extrem schmerzhaft
wenn ich hingegen die wertlosigkeit auf
eine einzelne handlung beziehen kann
ja dann bin ich nicht ganz davon
betroffen und deshalb ist es ist es
immer eine mögliche option
die psychologisch ganz nahe liegt dann
in die gegen aggression zu schalten und
nicht also entweder sich absichtlich
besonders schamlos zu benehmen
da kann man ja später sagen ja die
mochten mich nicht ja ich habe mich auch
ganz daneben benommen nicht und so also
man schiebt es dann auf das verhalten
und die aggression die aus beschämung
entsteht die kann eben auch sehr schnell
dazu führen dass jemand in einer
aggression übergeht und dann etwas tut
womit er sich schuldig macht ein
gewalttat eine schwere beleidigung
aber auch wenn man das später bereut
ist das nicht so destruktiv für das
eigene selbstwertgefühl also einnahmen
will das überhaupt und wert zu sagen
okay es war nur eine handlung und nicht
eine eigenschaft an genau merkmal
vielleicht davon
heraus aus personen jetzt das klingt ja
auch sehr komplex auch diese distanz die
man zu sich selbst haben muss um sich
schämen zu können hat der mani matter
der sinkt das nur die menschen sich
schäden können dass uns das dass die
fans es ist die uns unterscheidet
formatieren hatte also recht dass nur
der mensch sich schämen kann ja ich bin
eben ich bin da nicht ganz sicher weil
ich den eindruck habe soziale tiere ich
hab' ich hatte einmal den eindruck bei
einem gorilla im zoo bei meinem hund
hatte ich den eindruck dass die auf
menschliche blicke sehr stark reagieren
mich und auch auf menschliche
situationen oft so reagieren dass es
ihnen unangenehm ist etwa angestarrt zu
werden
also ich erinnere mich ich weiß gar
nicht mehr was im zoo zürich war wie ich
einmal in einem zoo wo die gorilla
gruppe in einer sehr kleinen entfernung
zu den zuschauern war das war glaube ich
ein anderer zu dem alpha männchen
begegnete plötzlich stand ich vor mich
und ich merkte also erst ganz peinlich
berührt und drehte sich so etwas zur
seite also das war ganz klar eine
situation der beschämung also dieses
konnte nämlich ausweichen
ich hatte wirklich das gefühl empfindet
sich jetzt selbst in einer ganz
hilflosen situation aber es braucht
wahrscheinlich diese fähigkeit auf
distanz zu gehen zu sichern und sich
durch die augen der anderen auch zu
betrachten ein stück weit oder sich an
geblickt zu fühlen also wenn man wenn
man weiß dass man an geblickt werden
könnte
dann ergreift man ja schon von selbst
quasi vorsichtsmaßnahmen der färbung
nicht also indem man physisch sich etwas
anzieht
intellektuell sich rationalisierung
überlegt um bei damit meinem gespräch
ist nicht auf peinliche themen kommt
nicht also man wenn man miteinander
spricht ist ja genauso viel
ablenkungsmanöver wie mitteilung auch
unbedingt bewusst macht und das sind
also wenn man könnte sagen
wir sind die scham fühlen können und das
sind vermutlich vor allem menschen aber
vermutlich auch nicht nur haben immer
etwas zu verbergen ich also viel charme
steht einfach für diese problematische
sozial beziehung einerseits wollen wir
voll und ganz mit schwingen wir wollen
wahrgenommen werden wir wollen dabei
sein und gleichzeitig ist das aber mit
vielen reibungen verbunden und uns auch
nicht wirklich behaglich denn wir wollen
auch nicht aufgelöst werden im sozialen
wir müssen uns abgrenzen und das führt
zu vielen manöver nicht also der der
scham abwehr sozusagen werden sie dann
sagen dieses gefühl ist kulturell
anerzogen weil bei ganz kleinen kindern
hat man das gefühl dass die keinen
charme empfinden haben sondern dass das
er aber einen bestimmten alter ab einer
bestimmten phase dann einsetzt ja aber
ich denke alle alle menschen haben diese
disposition also die sich dann erst im
laufe der kindheit entwickelt und welche
form sie dann annehmen das hängt
natürlich auch selbst stammt von der
kultur ab und das hängt natürlich auch
von den sozialen rollen ab das ist jetzt
bei kleinen jungen nicht unbedingt
dasselbe wie bei kleinen mädchen und
also die welche arten von schamhaft ich
kite für angebracht gelten das ist ja
oft sehr nach geschlechterrollen codiert
und da lernen die individuen sich hinein
zu finden oder auch nicht also das kann
natürlich auch konfliktreich seien
würden sie denn sagen in der heutigen
zeit schämen sich frauen frauen eher als
männer gibt es ein
geschlechterunterschied was shaman geht
in unserer kultur immer mensch sind wir
ja in einer übergangszeit wo sich viele
so rasant verändert dass das ganz schwer
zu sagen ist also als ich aufwuchs in
den 60er jahren hätte ich die frage ich
jetzt noch bejaht nicht also dass er
wurde von mädchen
wesentlich mehr schamhaft ich kite und
zurückhaltung erwartet also jedenfalls
in meiner familie meine mutter und meine
großmutter bei der wir wohnten die liegt
mir immer sehr nah zurückhaltend
aufzutreten
das war ganz klar ein bus bei jungen
hingegen nicht
das hat sich aber inzwischen sehr
geändert und im moment habe ich eher das
gefühl dass kulturell ist für frauen ein
bisschen leichter ist als für männer
weil männer die sehr starken druck
ausgesetzt sind sich nichts wie
toxischer männer im sinne dieser
toxischen wendigkeit zu verhalten
aber was soll das heißen nicht also die
ich denke es ist für männer im moment
sehr schwierig eine rolle zu finden mit
der sie auf unkomplizierte weise einfach
leben können ohne ständig darüber zu
reflektieren ob da eventuell sexismus
dabei ist oder ob das dem ideal der
männlichkeit nicht gerecht wird
sie sehen im moment mit sehr vielen auch
ab teilweise widersprüchlichen
ansprüchen aber es gibt natürlich sehr
viele frauen die immer noch sagen würden
dass der anpassungsdruck bei frauen eben
noch viel viel höher ist als bei männern
im vergleich aber acht dazu haben wir
mal eine sendung gemacht zu den männern
bildern die findet man noch haften auf
dem netz jetzt will mich noch
interessieren die biologie geht davon
aus dass gefühle eine funktion haben
eine primäre funktion also angst zum
beispiel schützt mich davor vor gefahren
zb oder ekel schützt mich davor
ungenießbare dinge zu essen was würden
sie denn sagen ist die funktion von
scham
ja das kommt jetzt darauf an auf welche
phänomene wir den begriff beziehen also
der ausdruck charme steht dafür soll ein
ganzes eine ganze gruppe von phänomen
dazu gehört die scham heftigkeit nicht
aber auch die schande
also die die sozial codierte exponierung
von etwas als schlecht im öffentlichen
raum
dazu gehört die scham angst und die
beschämung nicht also macht macht
manöver dass man andere beschämt ich
denke bei der schamhaft ich kite kann
man sicher sagen dass sie dem schutz des
individuums dient nicht also vor dinge
zu tun also es quasi sowieso aber wie so
eine innere warnung die einen davon
abhält unvorsichtigerweise dinge zu tun
die einen im öffentlichen raum
reaktionen aussetzen würden die man
vielleicht nicht mehr gut handhaben kann
und weil man auch nicht möchte schulz
ein schutz vor ungewollten sanktionen
könnt ja ja ja vor ungewollten sanktion
von führer pol reaktion ähnlich wie
bedrohlich werden könnten ähnlich wie
das gefühlte reue dass man zeigt man
bereut es und dadurch irgendwie
wahrscheinlich hier nicht bestraft wird
ja also die öffentliche reue
[Musik]
diddy ist quasi ein bestandteil von
wiedergutmachungs ritualen also man hat
eine andere person verletzt nicht oder
eine norm verletzt indem man öffentlich
reue bekundet
dann zeigt man einerseits der person
respekt also man hätte sich nicht so
verhalten soll welche andererseits zeigt
man sich aber auch als norm treu man man
ist eigentlich kein mensch der so etwas
tut
aber das ist natürlich im nachhinein und
die scham heftigkeit ist sozusagen die
handy hält einen davon ab überhaupt
diese daumen überschreitung oder
grenzüberschreitungen zu tun
jetzt haben sie schon gesagt die charme
ist zwar als disposition das möglichkeit
an geboren aber je nach kultur sieht sie
dann anders als wir schämen uns für ganz
unterschiedliche dinge und diese
schamgrenzen die verschieben sich auch
mit der zeit und ich habe den eindruck
seit einigen monaten und jahren ist
wieder vermehrt von schauen die rede im
öffentlichen raum
ich habe sie eine anmoderation gesagt
flugschau man sollte jetzt eben dafür
dass ich den liga nehmen nach ibiza oder
nach nach spanien impfung haben wir
gelernt gibt es oder die korona auch
beim husten
eben im tram zb dann auch in den
sozialen medien was oft berichtet wir
dass es gibt eine kultur bett der
beschämung von anderen public schimming
bodyshaping haben sie auch das gefühl
wir erleben so etwas wie eine
renaissance an eine eine wiedergeburt
oder dann wieder aufgenommen und diese
hat dieser charme kultur ja nicht
unbedingt im sinne von dem was
ethnologen klassischen kulturen nennen
aber was wir sicher erleben ist es quasi
einen ausbreiten
ein ausbreiten woran moralisierender
betrachtung nicht im öffentlichen raum
also für alle möglichen dinge die früher
moralischen neutral gewesen wären sie
haben ja das fliegen genannt das was man
isst das fahrzeug was man benutzt also
ganz viele dinge die früher schlichtweg
nicht in den bereich von dingen gehört
hätten über die man anderen moralische
vorwürfe macht sind jetzt plötzlich
moralisch codiert und das setzt leute
natürlich scham und schuldgefühlen aus
andererseits kann man sich fragen wie
ernsthaft das ist denn wenn der bereich
dessen für den mann eine moralisch
zuständig ist sich immer weiter
ausbreitet dann wird es natürlich auch
relativ dünn mich und also ich bin mir
da selbst nicht so ganz im klaren ob das
eine ernsthafte moralität ist oder eher
so eine dramatisierte moralität dass
jetzt plötzlich alle möglichen fragen
dann eben auch mit dem ton moralischer
kritik oder selbstkritik versehen will
ja eigentlich scheint doch eher eine
echte moralität zu sein da irgend mit
dem fliegen
stoss ich co2 aus indem ich irgendwie
fleisch esse auch also diese
alltagshandlungen wir sehen ja die
zusammenhänge inwiefern wir beitragen
zum übel der welt oder andere ausbeuten
mit den kleidern die wir kaufen
headshops und so weiter insofern will
ich schon sagen diese lokalisierung des
alltags das will ich teilen
aber das ist doch eine echte zum echten
moral also wenn das echte moral wäre
dann wären ja zum beispiel die wähler
der grünen sehr unmoralisch denn
diejenigen die am meisten fliegen also
von der bevölkerung in deutschland etwa
sind statistisch so weit ich das
sobald ich das gelesen habe die wähler
der grünen
ich war sie einfach
bevölkerungsschichten angehören die viel
fliegen und ich glaube aber nicht dass
das die unmoralische menschen sind als
andere sondern ich habe eher den
eindruck dass diese thematisierung von
dingen die man nicht allein sich selbst
zu rechnet moralisch sondern wo die
eigene handlung quasi ein kleines
elements einer riesenmenge von
handlungen ist sie zusammengenommen eine
sehr unerwünschte wirkung ergeben dass
ja heute tormann deswegen findet dass
das sollte man nicht tun
das hat nicht die selbe rückkoppelung
auf das auf das eigene handeln denn wenn
man jetzt die frage macht man jetzt eine
sehr lange reise mit dem zug eine
tagelange reise eventuell anstatt ein
flugzeug zu benutzen
bei einem einzelnen anlass beantwortet
dann kommt ein
die entscheidung jetzt die zugreise zu
machen und verhältnismäßig vor nicht im
vergleich zu den vielen terminen die man
vielleicht ausfallen lassen müsste usw
also man die art wie man kalkuliert wenn
man seine privat entscheidung abwägt
nicht also sollte man dies oder jenes
machen
sie lässt sich einfach nicht gut auf
diese fragen übertragen ich denke die
können nur auf der politischen ebene
gelöst werden also durch benzinsteuer
was was flugzeuge angeht
durch restriktionen was fernflüge angeht
und dergleichen also weil gerade die ich
auf dieser ebene der privat moral wir
sollten nicht zu viel last der
verantwortung auf die einzelnen märchen
übertragen wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
sondern die sie die schrauben drehen am
system die politischen jetzt reden sie
aber trotzdem davon dass viele von
unseren chronisch schlechten gewissen
leiden in unseren breitengraden würden
sie sagen wir machen uns zu viele
schuldgefühle falsche schuldgefühle die
vielleicht sogar ja also ich hab ich
habe manchmal den eindruck es wir
bewegen uns im grunde noch in dieser
tradition also der für die frühe der
sünden begriff stand nicht die
vorstellung dass man ein eingebettet ist
in einen zusammenhang von handlungen in
ein- oder in ein lebenszusammenhang der
insgesamt nicht der richtige ist also
der nicht der gottes gefällige ist wo
man auf die falschen dinge achtet oder
die falschen dinge wichtig findet wo man
eigentlich andere dinge wichtig finden
müsste dafür stand ja früher der begriff
sünde mich und sünde war aber nicht
unbedingt etwas dem einzelnen moralisch
vorwerfbares sondern stand eben für die
falsche haltung gegenüber dem ganzen
also gegenüber gott die von anfang an
mit der erbsünde auch schon schon da ist
das heißt ja wenn der geburt ist man ein
sünder
genau das ist einfach eine eigenschaft
des menschlichen und das ist dieser
aspekt der süden begriffs erleichtert
das einem natürlich auch damit umzugehen
denn wenn man weiß man ist zwar ein
sünder das ist auch irgendwie zeigt dass
das eigene leben falsch ist aber
andererseits sind menschen nun einmal so
das ist die erbsünde man kann darauf
hoffen dass gott ein vergibt dann ist
zumindest die anerkennung dieser
sündigen lebens eines was einem so
paradox das klingt auch wieder ein gutes
gewissen verschaffen kann ich also ich
weiß immerhin dass ich ein sünder bin
und ich habe den eindruck in diesen
gegenwärtigen moral diskussion spielt so
ein bisschen der ähnliche haltung eine
rolle
die werden dich wirklich so geführt mit
dem ziel ich ändere jetzt mein leben und
fliege jetzt nicht mehr also einzelne
individuum machen das vielleicht ja ich
habe mir schon unter anderem
leute mir erzählen warum sie nur noch
bio-produkte kaufen und nicht mehr
fliegen und nur noch mit dem zug
unterwegs sind habe ich schon geleitet
und dass die das bewusstsein haben sich
selbst können ein unterschied machen ja
ein bisschen
[Musik]
ich denke ich habe ich habe aber den
eindruck also gesamtgesellschaftlich ist
das hier ist das jetzt nicht dieselbe
ebene als wenn man sich sagen wir mal
selbst etwas vorwirft wie ein freund im
stich gelassen zu haben
eine person das persönlich schwer
verletzt zu haben also dinge die jetzt
wirklich speziell in der eigenen macht
stehen nicht und leider heute hat nur
sehr sehr genau so gering ist
jetzt müssen wir vielleicht trotzdem
nochmal die beiden begriffe scham und
schuld noch mal versuchen genau zu
trennen weil bei dieser flug charme und
so sind es ja eigentlich moralische
fehler aber sie haben gesagt
moralisierung des alltags ist der hand
tschuldigung fast schon keine beschämung
die da stattfindet oder wie würden sie
genau die unterscheidung treffen
zwischen scham und schuld die scham
betrifft ja die eigene persönlichkeit
als solche nicht also wenn ich mich
schäme
dann fühle ich mich wertlos in den
eigenen augen oder in den augen anderer
oder in den internet in dem was man
vielleicht als internalisieren blick
anderer bezeichnen könnte
also man man auch wenn andere nicht da
sind merkt man dass man etwas nicht
erreicht hat was man erreichen sollte
und man stellt sich etwa vor wie die
eltern wie die klassenkameraden oder so
darauf reagieren würden schult bezieht
sich auf das was man anderen schuldet
also man hat sich jemanden unfair
gegenüber verhalten man hat jemanden
verletzt man hat jemanden geschädigt und
das ist insofern bezogen auf die andere
person und kann auch wieder gut gemacht
werden
schuldgefühle können sie hier im manne
können sich oft auch weniger auf die
andere person als auf die norm richten
die man übertreten hat aber auch das
kann man bereuen nicht oder sich da sich
darzustellen
also schuld ist grundsätzlich wieder gut
machbar
man kann sich entschulden auf
unterschiedliche weisen aus der charme
situation kommt als solcher kommt man
nicht so leicht heraus
jedenfalls wenn sie tiefer geht nicht
weil sie zu mir die eigene wertlosigkeit
anzeigt
und dann braucht man strategien und
wieder selbstvertrauen zu gewinnen
jetzt gibt es ja in der geschichte eine
urszene könnte man sagen der der schaum
nämlich das paradies der sündenfall von
adam und eva ich habe ich hier eine
darstellung mitgebracht die schlange für
führt dann die eva dazu von einem
absolut zu essen man und auf der linken
seite und auf der rechten seite sieht
man dann dass sie plötzlich anfangen
erkennen nachdem sie vom baum der
erkenntnis des guten und bösen gegessen
haben erkennen sie dass sie nackt sind
davor nicht
und plötzlich bedecken sie ihre scham
was lernen wir aus dieser szene über den
begriff der charme und auch über das
schamhafte verhältnis zu unserem körper
generell ja das ist eine die also diese
diese paradies erzählung ist unglaublich
faszinierend weil man den eindruck hat
also da wird quasi seine seine
urgeschichte der individuation
beschrieben möchte individuen in der
situation ja denn vorher nehmen sich
adam und eva ja offenbar gar nicht als
körperliche wesen war also die
vereinzelt und voneinander getrennt sind
nicht sie sind zwar als zwei wesen da
aber dass sie wissen dass sie einen
körper haben dass der andere ein körper
hat dass sie sich als wechselseitig als
körperliche wesen wahrnehmen dass tritt
eben erst mit diesem erkenntnis akt auf
mich und die erkennen
das hat ja auch immer eine sexuelle
konnotation also in dem im alten
testament
wenn jemand seine frau erkennt dann
bedeutet das eine eheschließung ein
eine sexuelle beziehung es steht eine
geburt bevor es kennen erkennen und
schamhaft ich kite bedeuten bedeuten
eigentlich dasselbe zu realisieren dass
man verschieden ist nicht und sich aber
wechselseitig wahrnehmen dass man selbst
nicht einfach sagen wir mal diese reihen
diese reine subjektivität ist würde sie
es ausdrücken ich also die unmittelbar
in der welt existiert und einfach
wahrnimmt sondern ich bin ein
vereinzeltes wesen das von den anderen
wahrgenommen werden kann und eventuell
verurteilt für hässlich oder unmoralisch
gefunden werden kann
also ich bin selbst nicht nur subjekt
sondern objekt genau man sehr von den
blick in andere demnach bewerten können
und abwerten können sagte beschreibt das
ja als ein ursprüngliches gefühl der
ohnmacht ja ich also solange man sich
nicht daran denkt dass es andere gibt
ist man ja quasi allmächtig und
ungestört man bewegt sich durch die welt
und dann begegnet man den blick einer
anderen person und alles verändert sich
nicht also man weiß man ist in der welt
man ist diesen blick ausgeliefert man
kann nichts dagegen machen dass ein
andere beurteilen
die hölle das sind die anderen ich
brauche einsatz und sagen aber diese
diese ohnmacht die kann man natürlich
auch überwinden vielleicht sogar in
einer berechtigung indem man die eigene
scham überwindet auch zum eigenen körper
und da gibt es aus der filmgeschichte
ein schönes beispiel nämlich aus dem
film toni erdmann gegen ende des films
organisiert die hauptdarstellerin ein
geburtstags brunch bei sich zu hause und
merkt im letzten moment dass sie das
falsche kleid anhat und es klingt aber
schon an der tür und was dann passiert
schauen wir uns mal gemeinsam an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hey
[Musik]
ja da youtube
berlin - superstar event
basically
ja wir haben kein böses mikrometer
hauptsaison
schneider
nein
ja da steht dann der schon vor der türe
sie stellt sich noch mal selbstbewusst
hin da passiert einiges beim betrachten
dieses abschnitts auch in sachen
fremdschämen
wie deuten sie denn diese dieses ziel ja
also ich sehe sie natürlich vor dem
hintergrund des rest films nicht also
also bezogen
bezogen auf eine transformation
sozusagen dieser protagonistin der jenes
sie ist ja das muss man bei dieser szene
ja wissen also die es geht um einen
geburtstag der instrumentalisiert wurden
ist zu einem event das quasi der
förderung der unternehmenskultur dienst
nicht also eine rumänische ein
rumänischer gruppe und eine deutsche
gruppe die sollen bei diesem event
chance eben schön kontakt pflegen und es
soll ein bisschen locker werden und so
weiter also alles im dienste der
förderung der unternehmenskultur
[Musik]
ines ist wird eingeführt als eine sehr
angepasste person also die eigentlich
bereit ist ihre ganze freizeit also eben
auch diese geburtstag ehren ihrem chef
und dem unternehmen zu opfern
gleichzeitig aber als jemand die damit
nicht wirklich zufrieden ist also sie
das zeigt sich ja auch hier in dieser
szene sie wirkt sehr miesepetrig nicht
man weiß nicht ob diese diese petrich
jetzt kalt jetzt aufgesetzt sein soll
aber auf jeden fall ist sie auch latent
melancholisch das zeigt der film vorher
und in dieser szene wo das mit dem kleid
überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert da
gibt eben etwas um bei bier und das
erhält aber interessanterweise erst aus
dem ablauf der szene als also als
zuschauer haben wir ja auch
erwartungshaltungen und wir besitzen da
ja die ganze zeit ungeduldig und denken
ja wann zieht sie denn jetzt endlich
etwas an
das ist das witzige an dieser szene man
kann sich diese erwartung gar nicht
entziehen sich und wird immer irritiert
sie endlich da irgendetwas schlug und
dann zieht sie auch noch ihren slip aus
da merkel erst in diesem moment wo man
sich ja von hinten sieht wo man also
keine vorstellung davon haben kann was
in ihrem gesicht und also auch in ihrem
geist vorgeht wird klar dass es sich um
dass sich da etwas verändert hat nicht
und die enorme zurückhaltung die sonst
legt wir haben ja schon über
zurückhaltend gesprochen also sie ist ja
sonst die perfektion des zurück der
zurückhaltende nach einer anpassung
erwartungen genau
na ja genau das geht hier vollkommen
verloren
sie übernimmt jetzt die aktivität und
nötigt ihrem chef der jetzt vor der türe
steht einen akt party auf
genau dann ungeheuer irgendwie diese
selbstüberwindung die darin steckt hat
aber trotzdem das ungeheuer befreien das
auch nämlich von den erwartungen der
anderen einfach sich mal los zu machen
und dass sie das ist ja schon dieses
emanzipatorische potenzial der scham
überwindung auch zum beispiel die
amerikanische sozialwissenschaftlerin
schaum forscherin
premier brown die schreibt charme sei
eigentlich immer destruktiv und sie
fordert schämt euch nicht also wir
müssen uns eigentlich doch für sehr
wenig schämen aus menschen und ich
glaube diese einsicht kommt da auch
durch das schaue mir bei wenigen etwas
extrem befreien das sein kann sein kann
ja also ich denke solche
verallgemeinerungen sind immer
problematisch den charme hat natürlich
normalerweise auch eine schutzfunktion
aber in situationen wo charme in dem
sinne operativ ist dass die dass die
angst vor beschämung menschen in
sozialen verhältnissen hält die für sie
nieder drückend sind die ihre neigung
überhaupt nicht entsprechend nicht und
die die sie daran hindern ihre talente
auszuleben
und das ist das ist in der vorgeschichte
relativ offensichtlich hier der fall
dann ist es nach hat es natürlich ein
unmittelbares befreiungs moment wenn
sich die person davon frei machen ja wie
nimmt denn mein chef mich war wie sie
wie bin ich rüber bekommen bei dieser
vorführung sondern ganz umgekehrt den
chef jetzt in eine situation nötig wo er
sich quasi den blicken anderer
ausgesetzt fühlt denn er wird ja später
auch da noch nackt bei dieser nacht
party erscheinen
genau jetzt gibt's davon friedrich
nietzsche einen schönen satz war sagt
das siegel der freiheit sozusagen wahre
freiheit bedeutet dass man sich nicht
mehr vor sich selbst schämen muss und
sie haben am anfang der sendung nach
unterschieden charme sozusagen vor den
anderen und charme vor mir selbst meinen
eigenen ideal nicht entsprechen können
würden sie den nietzsche zu stehen und
sagen das ist wahre befreien dass ich
mich selber nicht mehr vor mir selber
haben muss auch wenn sich die anderen
vielleicht noch fremd schämen für mich
ja auch das ist noch komplizierter also
ich denke wer gemeint hier an eine
internalisiert also die aus der
internalisierung konventioneller norden
kommen nicht und die mich daran abhält
zb bestimmte gedanken mich überhaupt
zutrauen zu denken wenn ich das ist ja
für nietzsche als jemand der großen wert
darauf legt auch unerlaubte gedanken in
allen konsequenzen denken und ausdrücken
zu können etwas ganz wesentliches dass
ich mich traue also dinge zu denken wie
mitleid ist nicht unbedingt immer gut
also andere christliche werte zu
kritisieren nicht die etwa in seinem
elternhaus von fahrern und
eingetrichtert wurden genau ja die
eingetrichtert worden
aber nietzsche an einer anderen stelle
weist auch darauf hin dass beschämung
sogar etwas befreiendes sein kann das
setzt allerdings sei ein gewisses
selbstvertrauen voraus nämlich wenn man
feststellt dass man
das dass es menschen gibt die genau das
tun was man gerne tun würde aber nicht
getan hat das ist eine total beschämende
erfahrung weil man sich dann als sehr
viel konventioneller ängstlicher und
kreativer fühlt als man sein möchte
gleichzeitig weiß man erlebt man aber
durch die scham
das ist etwas möglich ist das beschreibt
er in einer situation in der abhandlung
schopenhauer als erzieher von der zeit
als er zum ersten mal auf schopenhauer
gestoßen ist und vollkommen begeistert
war dass jemand so unkonventionell und
auch rücksichtslos schreiben kann nicht
und sich zutiefst beschämt fühlte weil
er sein weil er plötzlich seine eigene
schriftstellerin susan das war neben dj
diese beschämung die beschreibt er
glaube ich als eine scham ohne
verdrossenheit also eine scham die
gerade nicht von der traurigkeit des
niedergedrückten selbstwertgefühls
begleitet ist sondern auch etwas
befreiendes hans nicht interessant
merkel plötzlich das ist doch viel
weniger wert gewesen als ich dachte
nicht aber gleichzeitig öffnet sich eine
neue möglichkeit eine neue welt also
diese charme hat immer diese ambivalenz
zwischen gut und schlecht aber auch
zwischen lähmend und irgendwie antreiben
dass es schon treibt leute auch auf die
straße löst soziale bewegungen also
etwas das der us amerikanische
politologe francis fukuyama beschreibt
in dem man auch in wut umschlagen kann
zum beispiel und dieser fehlende stolz
timos nennt diesen griechischen begriff
das hat eine eine sehr bewegende
funktion und das erläuterte er in hier
in einem gespräch in der sternstunde
philosophie vor allem mehr zeit wir
hören immer das altgriechische wort
thymus bezeichnet das universelle
streben nach anerkennung
die menschen wollen mehr als nur
materialistische dinge es
trinken und geld für den respekt unsere
mitmenschen sind wir sogar bereit auf
wirtschaftliche vorteile zu verzichten
das bewegt auch die politik ich bin mit
dem großen philosophen hegel einig den
diesem geltung streben eine stärke
antriebskraft für den fortschritt der
geschichte erkannte
so erhoben sich zur zeit der
französischen revolution die sklaven
weil sie ihre menschenwürde nicht
respektiert sahen dieses schreiben
einzelner gruppen nach würde und
anerkennung ist eine der wichtigsten
antriebsfedern in der moderne koyama
geht noch einen schritt weiter sagt
nicht nur bürgerrechtsbewegung oder
feminismus ist getrieben durch diese
anerkennung sehnsucht sondern auch so
etwas wie rechtspopulismus oder
extremismus islamismus als er versucht
ganz unterschiedliche soziale bewegung
strömung so zu erklären indem er diesen
diese anerkennung dieser fehlenden
charme der gegenseite gegenteil von
schauen gleich stolz zone ungeheurer
wichtigkeit gibt können sie das
nachvollziehen
ja also es kommt mir sehr plausibel vor
also die also wenn man das vergleicht
mit der sagen wir mal noch so in den
60er 70er jahren vorherrschenden
vorstellung dass soziale bewegung
hauptsächlich durch wirtschaftliche
faktoren entstehen nämlich also die
armen protestieren nicht weil sie weil
sie eben kaum die möglichkeiten zum
überleben haben
da hat man sich soziale bewegung
hauptsächlich aus materiellen faktoren
erklärt nicht aber damit die ganzen
auseinandersetzung zwischen islamischen
bereich zwischen den verschiedenen
formen von islam nicht und die proteste
einzelner minderheiten kann man sich
damit überhaupt nicht erklären ich weiß
es geht wesentlich um das gefühl
obwohl man eigentlich eigentlich als
gleichberechtigt war nimmt eben doch
nicht gleichberechtigt zu sein nicht
sondern verächtlich behandelt zu werden
und dass da kein einzelne beschämung
auslöser sein also zum beispiel der
arabische frühling wurde ja dadurch
ausgelöst dass ein gemüsehändler der
einen illegalen stand hatte von einer
polizistin vertrieben und dabei auf
offenbar auf eine weise die als kränkend
empfand angesprochen wurde
ich empfand das als eine zumutung dass
eine frau in soll harris behandelt nicht
und und auch als das dass er bloß weil
sein stand illegal war das aber
eigentlich eine normale sache war nicht
jetzt plötzlich ausgesondert und
demütigend herabwürdigend schämt so
genau also solche bestimmung des
erfahrung die können so tief gehen ich
also der wenn man sowieso schon
angespannt ist und dann kommt so etwas
hinzu das hat bei ihm ja offenbar ein
eine aufregung und eine ausgelöste in
verzweiflung mündete und schließlich
dazu führte dass er sich an zündet nicht
und das muss von vielen als etwas
empfunden zu sein was so stark ihre
eigene situation aus anspricht dass das
eine soziale bewegung ausgelöst hatte ja
dann also über die ganzen arabischen
länder übergriff ist glaubt dass ich
sagen von vielen also diese idee das
schon auch etwas kollektives sein kann
es gab diesen sturm marx kapital in den
usa und das sprach barack obama von
einem moment der schande und der charme
für das ganze land
das heißt es gibt es auch schon
geteilten kollektive charme einer ganzen
bevölkerung als groß teil der
bevölkerung ja also ich denke charme hat
ja eben nichts mit nicht primär mit
eigenen handlungen zu tun sondern mit
der eigenen identität mit dem womit man
sich identifiziert nicht und
entsprechend kann man sich natürlich
auch darüber wenn das die deutsche
nationalmannschaft bei der letzten em so
früh ausgeschieden ist zu tief stehen
als deutsche oder natürlich gar erst
recht als amerikaner
wenn ausgerechnet so ein symbol der
nationalen einheit und der funktion des
funktionierenden politischen systems wie
das capitol durch eine derartige gruppe
von also sich in den augen anderer
ungebührlich aufführenden auch nicht
richtig kriegerischen gruppe also dass
katar
da kann man schon verstehen dass das als
eine nationale demütigung empfunden wird
auch wenn es kein angriff von außen ist
es beschämt mich obwohl ich diese
handlung nicht verzogen haben wir die
anderen irgendwie teil dieser nation
sind wo ich acht teil davon bin und das
ist wahrscheinlich auch der unterschied
zum fremdschämen wo man sich ja auch
schämt für das verhalten anderer aber
sich nicht so wirklich identifiziert
sondern man grenzt sich ab und freut
sich vielleicht sogar darüber dass ja
wahrscheinlich ist genau solche tv
sendungen wie
der bachelor wie man das nicht ist er
sehr beliebt und viele hört man schauen
dass ja nur als könnten des
fremdschämens ja aber das fremd also
diese art von fremdschämen ist ja eben
nicht wirklich ein einschub für das was
andere tun nicht so wie das bei der
kollektiven charme ist sondern es ist ja
eher so ein genüssliches so eine art
schadenfreude möchte also dass das
andere das andere in peinliche
situationen geraten ich und wir werden
wenn jemand sagt für das was sie getan
haben musste ich mich fremd schämen
dann ist das normalerweise eine
beleidigung also dass das man auf etwas
hingewiesen wird was angeblich zum
schämen ist nicht und quasi eine eher
eine indirekte weise darauf bezug zu
nehmen
gegen ende des gesprächs möchte ich noch
mal ein bisschen auf distanz gehen und
schauen wenn sich die schamgrenzen
verschieben kann man nachfragen normativ
sollte man sie denn verschieben und wenn
ja wohin die frage wäre also gibt es
dinge für die wir uns heute schämen wo
sie aber sagen würden
dafür sollten wir uns nicht schämen oder
nicht mehr schämen und auf der anderen
seite die frage gibt es dinge die wir
einfach so tun die uns kalt lassen wo es
sie aber sagen würden das sollten wir
uns eigentlich dafür schämen ja ich war
also ich hab den eindruck also
aufforderung sich zu schämen sollten
vernünftigerweise mehr an individuen
oder oder vielleicht kleine gruppen
gerichtet werden
die gerade etwas falsch machen also so
im sinne in diesem sinne eines solchen
kulturellen wie würde ich sie eher im
würde ich sie eher als betrachtung ob
man etwas generell falsch macht oder
sich an etwas falschem orientiert
verstehen also nicht als aufforderung
jetzt wirklich gefühle zu entwickeln und
in dem sinne und anders zu handeln genau
ja also ich denke im moment haben wir
ein bisschen ist vielleicht unsere unser
problem dass wir uns zu viel schämen was
ansprüche alles korrekt zu machen angeht
und dass wir im moment sogar dazu neigen
die vergangenheit immer mehr einer
moralisierenden perspektive zu
unterziehen bis hin zum kollektiven
schämen also etwa kolonial scham nicht
weiter und so weiter also dass wir uns
für unsere eigene kolonialgeschichte
schämen oder für uns weiß sein dass
meinen sie jetzt das große lauter dem
geschehen die jetzt gar nicht in unserer
macht stehen so die die eben
problematische aspekte der eigenen
vergangenheit betreffen
anstatt dass wir uns mit dem
beschäftigen was in unserer macht steht
richter also ich habe im moment den
eindruck also seitdem zusammen fall des
ostblocks
das ist eine tendenz zum ersatz handeln
oder ersatz moralisieren geht nicht also
statt zu überlegen wenn man etwa an
fragen der gerechtigkeit denkt was eine
was eine gerechte wirtschaftsordnung die
auch realisierbar wie ihre sein könnte
sich und sich mit den fragen der
gestaltung der zukunft beschäftigt
wenden wir im moment unseren blick auf
eine weise die es vielleicht noch nie
gegeben hat auf die vergangenheit und
überlegen was in der vergangenheit alles
falsch gemacht wurde stichwort quadrant
ein rassist
ja also wir beschäftigen uns mit der
damit ob man die geisteshaltung von
personen vor 200 jahren im lichte
unserer norm jetzt zu verurteilen hat
und das kommt mir merkwürdig vor
nicht also ich finde wir müssten und so
es gibt ungeheuer viele zukunftsaufgaben
die wir im moment angehen und
diskutieren müssten und dass eine so
große aufmerksamkeit
mit blick auf unsere gegenwärtigen
moralischen vorstellungen auf die
diskussion der vergangenheit gerichtet
also da ich glaube nicht dass man sich
darüber jetzt wiederum schämen sollte
seine energien
da etwas umschichten hat die der gedanke
ist doch dass die vergangenheit immer
noch nachwirkt und unser denken von
heute immer noch prägt und das natürlich
eine steile these wenn sie sagen die
ganze politische korrektheit
vielleicht auch identitätspolitik dass
diese märkte so wichtig sind die
hautfarbe geschlecht herkunft dass das
nur eine ersatzhandlung ist wie sie
gesagt haben aber weil das in unserer
macht steht nicht also ich sehe ich habe
den eindruck das ist eine haltung die
aus einem gewissen ohnmachtsgefühl
geboren ist das mit dem fall der mauer
eben auch die sozialistischen utopien
mehr oder weniger weggefallen sind nicht
und wir große schwierigkeiten haben
andere hoffnung und utopien aufzubauen
nicht und ein gefühl der ohnmacht und
das ist immer ganz leicht auf das
moralische feld auszuweichen weil man
das scheinbar in der hand hat mich also
ob man sich rassistisch sexistisch
verhält oder wie man das beurteilt das
ist etwas was anscheinend in der eigenen
macht ist nicht was man sich selbst und
anderen vorwerfen kann aber sehr komisch
weil sie davor haben sie gesagt die
eigene vergangenheit der eigenen
hautfarbe das ist ja nicht etwas das
sich verändern kann
das ist einfach da und daher habe es
beurteilen
das steht natürlich in der eigenen macht
ich kann darüber diskutieren ob kant ein
rassist war und ich kann ich kann
darüber dass über die kreuzzüge die vor
1000 jahren passiert sind diskutieren
und sie beurteilen und ich also das
beurteilen das moralische urteilen das
ist immer etwas was in meiner eigenen
macht darf war würden sie sagen machen
ihnen im moment zu viel da machen wir zu
viele ich sage nicht das ist
grundsätzlich falsch aber ich habe den
eindruck es sollte nicht als eine
ersatzhandlung benutzt werden ja da
müsste man die motive genau anschaue es
war eine lange und interessante
diskussion die wir leider jetzt nicht
mehr erfüllen können aber ich habe sehr
viel gelernt über schuld und beschämung
vielen herzlichen dank
carlotta ja ich danke ihnen für die
spannende diskussion danke auch ihm fürs
mitdenken nächste woche widmen wir uns
der so genannten cancel die mit dem
zusammenhängt was wir gerade besprochen
haben barbara bleisch und wolfram
eilenberger sprechen mit ihren gästen am
philosophischen stammtisch über das
umstrittene phänomen fragen darf man
personen aus der öffentlichkeit
verbannen weil sie bestimmte meinungen
vertreten
zu gast sind die gender forscherin
franziska schutzbach und der
literaturkritiker ijoma mangold jetzt
gleich zeigen wir den film die
unbeugsamen drei frauen die dafür
kämpfen dass vor gut 100 jahren das
frauenwahlrecht in deutschland und
österreich eingeführt wurde in der
schweiz dauert es ja bekanntlich wieder
einmal etwas länger bleiben sie also
dran und ein schön so
[Musik]